who wait this actually got really weird
that's her mom that's her mom the mom
been knowing that this dude been putting
hands on her for more than a year and
they sit together on a podcast like
nothing happening you know what's good
when you find up somebody that loves you
that respects you that makes you feel
good that enhances your life screw the
money know what I shocking allegations
of domestic from popular TV personality
Kiki Palmer the former host of gma3 and
the game show password has been granted
a temporary restraining order against
her ex-boyfriend you don't remember this
guy um he was the guy who was mad cuz
his uh and the mother of his CH child
was dancing with Usher that's stff
happened you know internet lost it this
guy got online said y That's she a mom
though why she up here grinding on us or
a lot of people felt some type way comes
out recently that she filed a
restraining order against him uh for
allegations of now let's up the actress
who famously showed off her belly bump
when she appeared on SNL submitted
shocking images to the court taken from
surveillance video including this one of
her being thrown over the back of a sofa
his hand around her throat Kiki Palmer
alleges the domestic occurred here at
her Los Angeles home over the course of
two years and she says the most recent
incident happened last Sunday it got so
bad she called police on the phone that
the suspect was attempting to kill her
in the court documents Palmer says the
abuse included striking and grabbing me
around the neck and threatening to kill
himself with a gun if I left him Palmer
says the gone on for 2 years these
photos from 2022 show Jackson allegedly
manhandling her she ends up at the
bottom of the stairs she also accuses
him of hitting me in front of our son
and spewing profanities about me to our
son Palmer's mother Sharon weighed in on
the accusations last night saying she
reached out to Jackson's brother I went
to chiron's over a year ago and told him
that his brother was a to my daughter to
refresh everybody's memory so Gabrielle
Union a couple of weeks ago she had
spoke about how she and Dwayne go 5050
like that's important to her she feels
like you know he does this she does that
and that's how they do it and Dwayne
came back out cuz they you know Gabby
actually received some flak uh about
that um and Dwayne comes back and he
speaks to it as well and here's my
thing I grew up in a home you know you
and Dad y'all been together for over 30
years y'all 35 35 I remember when y'all
both was doing the factory shift
together that's right y'all have always
done everything 50 well wait this
actually got really
weird that's her mom that's her mom the
mom been knowing that this dude been
putting hands on her for more than a
year I went to chironis over a year ago
and told him that his brother was a and
they sitting together on a podcast like
nothing
happening well the only difference is
that there's no red table but it's a
talk yo this [__]
weird ain't that weird Okay hypothetical
I'm just trying to match this in my own
life this is never happened will never
happen but let's say hypothetically God
forbid I'm beating my girl
me and my girl decid to run a
podcast and her dad knows I'm beating
his
daughter I'm sorry when you say like
that it makes no goddamn sense you think
he just going to be sitting up on this
podcast talk about compromis and
settling you know what the thing is I
think so there's some people that are
that are like that because of I'm going
tell you something I'm going tell you
something coming from a Haitian
background Haitians are like I say
Haitian they PR like nothing happen
Haitian because that's that's what I
know okay but I know there's a lot of
Caribbean people and immigrant people
that are like that you know it that they
going to out in public they going to
hide all that cuz they have to look good
one of the thing your Haitian parent is
going to say to discipline you is what
are the others are going to say what are
they going to say about me at church
they say that stuff so you think they
prioritized that over the safety of
their child I they I'm asking I'm I feel
like sometimes it's not really like how
you just said it but the outcome is
exactly what you said but what they
trying to protect is the name because
especially if your child has is a public
figure or whatever whatnot they're going
to how they're going to keep to
themselves but between closed doors they
know yeah they know a bunch of [__] and
that's that's in the realm of if the
person is known like KY palmer but if we
take that the fact that if we know we
take away the fact that you know uh the
person is known Within the family
there's some [__] that happening that
some people know and they will shut the
[__] up about that people in the family
groping people and you can't say [__]
because I can't say that Uncle Tay Tay
does this [__] and that [__] no you
can't talk about that [__] I say Haitian
but I know a lot of black folks and a
lot of immigrant folks that it's like
that in their family too so if you do go
ahead no I I know a lot I know a lot of
black folks and a lot of immigrant folk
that it's like that in their family it
and that that's that is like that and
the parents going to sit here be like
mhm yeah mhm and go over everything and
stuff and not going to a the the thing
out she's not sitting it's not like the
mom is sitting with the dude that she
don't like and they're disgusting is
that the man right next to her
yeah I need a minute yeah that the doooo
beating is her daughter is sitting right
beside her on this podcast and you know
what I still think it's possible in a I
I actually agree because you have to
imagine right when you're in this cycle
and people are getting beat right you
have to imagine it's a EB and flow thing
it's bad one moment then it's great one
moment I like I don't know what this
kind of dynamic is like but I've
definitely been Dynamics where it's like
roller coaster so I could imagine she
like okay things are better now Mom and
we we patch things up so the mom may
come on the podcast thinking things are
hunky dory me personally I can take me
out of it because I'm not them I could
never be that man sitting on that
podcast right there if I done that to
her daughter because I would feel Shain
for so long I couldn't even look her
until I felt like I really made a m okay
but could be on a podcast talking about
relationships and settling like I'll be
like considering what I did I I can't I
Beil exactly that's why I take myself
out of it that's my whole point yeah
looking at this situation these are
completely removed people who may not
feel any of those things I'm looking at
them like I don't know how you could be
on that podcast if it was me I feel but
they not me so who cares right I'm
looking at this mom and it's like if I'm
the parent that could never be me
either you put hands on my child man or
woman yo I don't want to be seen in
public with you y'all better get some
counseling if you come into Christmas
y'all better not talk to me y'all I
won't be mean if y'all fixing your [__]
but if it's not being fixed don't even
think about coming through my [__]
door Hey listen I'm sorry that's just
not me I can't do it and if I'm the one
getting beat yo forget a podcast yo we
talk streaming orders we talking about
you out the door everything but again
I'm saying this on the outside looking
in so who really cares but that's a
thing in the family when there's
something that everybody knows and
people don't say it do you know
something a meme a series of meme called
Thanksgiving clapbacks uhhuh you know
that no those clapbacks are basically
depicting that everybody in the family
know secret is gathering in in at
Thanksgiving and someone has the
audacity to tell you some [__] but they
[__] is not proper sort sort like the
Auntie is going to be like M wasn't I I
wasn't drinking when I was inine you
can't drink when you're pregnant cuz
everybody knows that she's drinking
while she's pregnant nobody's saying
[__] cuz it's kind of a secret and
that's in the realm that me was trying
to
say basically like girl you were you
were pregnant at 16 no you were you were
you can't drink when you're pregnant
that means that she was drinking when
she was pregnant no that's all that
means I wasn't drinking when I was 16
her you can't drink when you're pregnant
pregnant and drinking no because she was
pregnant at 16 and drinking no she
that's why she couldn't drink because
she was pregnant at
16 you understand I see what you're
saying so the girl the girl the girl so
so so so the aunt is like yo why your 16
year-olds drinking it's like oh ma don't
worry about it the reason why you wasn't
drinking at 16 is cuz you was too busy
being pregnant I get I get what you're
saying I get what you're saying yeah
same point oh yeah same point same point
the aun se's see your acting is coming
back unlike your husband everybody knows
some [__]
but you have the it's because she had a
husband at
16 okay now I'm just trolling yeah I
know you're trolling but you know what I
mean so in the family in the family
Dynamic it's like that and now you add
on top of that the layer that Kiki is no
known so at the podcast I'mma shut the
[__] up and B my lips about some [__] I
know but I'll be like you know what it's
my daughter and I'm not going to do you
like that because I love you and yes in
that case the point and the intention is
not to surpass your security over your
your over the Silence of everything and
stuff but the but the but the outcome is
that I think this is actually the
craziest part of this story the mom got
on a podcast with the person who was her
daughter and they all act like
everything's cordial it really speaks to
how like Society speaking within
families like a lot of this stuff is
well known to happen and just people go
like but sometimes it's also you know
yeah but I say for me and any family I
would Foster I could never but other we
don't know what the dynamic is and also
the fact that they want to protect their
child but they don't want to seem like
the overbearing parent that always talk
[__] or always in into the child so
sometimes they take a they take a step
back when they shouldn't take a step
back I I
agree I think when there's fights
between couples I agree they beating
your child is different 100% but you
don't know what Kiki telling her mom no
no it's fine it's fine it's fine I do
know because the mom already said she'
been knowing for a year that this L this
man been beating her there's not like
they don't know I'm not going off rumors
it came out of the mom's own mouth that
she confronted the brother about the
fact that he beats her he did okay so
she knew so she knew I could understand
parents not want to be involved it's
your child your child's being physically
hurt that's your job at any age to be
invol I forgot she said that but she did
say that yes so to be clear that is
something that happened that is a
bizarre environment to me 100% look I
know oh her man is rich and this and
that and they've been through a lot and
bringing up all that they pass and my
opinion about that is like at the end of
the day if you marry somebody aren't you
guys supposed to be a partnership and
here we are in a generation where
everybody's like no gender rules no
gender rules but soon as it gets down to
paying something it's like he better pay
for that like why I need us to make up
our mind I don't know what what do you
guys think to me it's just seems like
you know you start to limit yourself
when it comes to that just thinking at
that moment in time as well it's just
like what if you come across somebody
that had like that that does everything
but you know he want like maybe he wants
to do 50/50 or you know you make more
than him but it's just like well you're
going to shut that down because oh I
think a lot of people will shut that
down you know what's good when you find
somebody that loves you that respects
you that makes you feel good that
enhances your life screw the money you
know what I mean I'm not going to go
find the rest of this podcast uh but I'm
actually curious from your guys's
perspective how would you guys react in
this kind of scenario being one of I
want you guys to think of all three
perspectives let's say it's your family
member who's in that relationship would
you guys be on the podcast let's say you
like doing podcast and you're fine with
it okay hypothetical would you guys be
okay with doing the podcast and sitting
beside the man who hurting your sibling
your daughter whatever it might be bro
why wouldn't you why would I I I want to
see comments below explaining some of
this [__] for you what if you guys are
the ones who did the beating how would
you guys react I I just this is so crazy
to me it's it's it's irrelevant but for
the exercise let's do it cuz none of us
are those people and none of us went
through what they went through
and maybe we don't have the illness that
they have mental health we don't have
the illness that they they have or the
issue that they have to do that but yes
for the exercise let's do that let's see
let's see what people think out there
and how would they feel cuz here's my
thing you made the things giving me
there's a lot of people who living that
scenario right
now A th% they know people getting beat
and they sitting around and they sitting
around and I want to hear from them if I
if I know me I can't sit at the table
with somebody I know beating somebody
else at the table that's me now I'm also
not somebody who's invited to a lot of
family dinners I'm okay with that I
sleep well at night I'm sorry I say this
all the time like my family you know
there's been a lot of theft there's been
a lot of Shenanigans in the background I
won't get too deep into it I don't talk
to certain uncles and aunts and cousins
for that reason and I'm okay with that I
think I sleep better because of it and
I'm not saying my choice is the right
one I'm saying it's right for me which
is different you know my mom sometimes
she coming to me with family drama I'm
like I don't want to hear about it I
already cut these people out of my life
I don't care what they doing I never
want to know what they doing I don't
even want to know these people exist
anymore as far as I'm concerned they
dead to me okay you come to hurt me I'm
not trying to do a welfare check
afterwards you want to know call the
police call mental health call the
firefighters they checking in on your
ass cuz it's not me I'm not coming with
no bucket of water I ain't come in with
no notepad find out what your problem is
and I come with no Bank check to help
nothing that's that's not my family no
more somebody else's problem I don't
want to have any updates I don't want to
know where they died how they died who
did it what did it not my
business but that's what works for me
that's what I had to do for me to
protect myself okay I want to know from
you guys' perspective I don't say it's
wrong I want to know like that mindset
so go ahead I want to tell you how Petty
I am go there's I got a situation like
that in my family my family members are
dead to me you understand what I'm
saying
um metaphorically they dead to me they
you can say metaphorically but I'mma
tell you and you decide how
metaphorically it is okay and I told my
mom that but she's kind of a little bit
of stubborn cuz she really wants the
connection and people that connect and
be on CA so she comes to me he like are
you going to go to the such and such
burd and I answer ain't that [__]
dead you know so funny
was perfect cuz I said Ain't That [__]
did I was looking to the camera to
figure it out to H that's beautiful oh
such such and such and such are you
going to go to the party party of what
then that [__] did that didn't that die
a couple years ago and she's like stop
it that [__] did I don't know I can't
he did she also accuses him of hitting
me in front of our son I
mean we'll
see I I guess she would have to go go to
court for that or whatever she has a
restraining order she has a restraining
order she has the footage to back it up
but then again like I said I wasn't
there so no I don't have much to say
about that okay so when a woman getting
beat you got nothing to say well yeah
it's bad it is
bad that's it that's all when a man
something happens you got 10 minutes
worth of video when it's a woman though
you got nothing to say she's doing what
she's supposed to do yeah like what I'm
going to State the obvious I'mma stay
the obvious yeah it's bad that he does
of course it's bad that he does that
what do you have to say I just think
it's crazy that when it came to her
being dancing with Usher There was a
full-on video yeah but now it's her
getting beat by the same man who had a
problem and now but it is crazy
everybody agrees I don't have to say
anything I don't have to prove well my
point is that it's bad people it's like
stating the obvious the thing about her
dancing with user was one thing because
people were very one-sided about a thing
but I'm pretty sure that everybody's on
the same page don't beat on
people [__] are you talking about you're
crazy I'm crazy you're [__] crazy I
think you're crazy you're starting I
think it's crazy that you got so much
energy for petty [__]
but you
trying sorry you look you really look
like you had a good stretch today you
sleep good you look like you you slept
good you got you sound like you got the
energy
I could reach yeah I see that that's a
reach that's a whole ass reach well I
just think it's surprising shut the [__]
up with shut the [__] up with that [__]
that's bogus ass [__] [__] of course
it is like it's bad I mean when everyone
sent us this story I kind of had the
same reaction I was like oh then send
his ass to jail I don't yeah send this
[__] to jail man did a crime I
guess some people felt some type of way
because we said a man feeling some type
of way about his girlfriend dancing with
Usher even if she's a performer is like
he's he's entitled to feel like he
doesn't want that in relationship those
two things are not the same like no
there's there's a middle ground between
that and being super controller you're a
dumb right think that so for me I don't
think those two incidents are linked I
think if he has Behavior like that and
also didn't like the fact that he was
out there online talking all this mess
if you had an issue with her doing that
stuff with Usher she could just keep it
offline top to her when you see her
you're not dating the internet you don't
got to be on Twitter shaming her and she
got to you know handle with you in these
images to me look really bizarre I don't
think there's a way you could really
describe it cuz here's the thing some
people might say well I but you don't
know the full story H what if the full
images come out and they show that she
was hitting on him too I'm going say
this whether it's her hitting on him or
hting on her okay none of this should
ever be happening in a relationship
there is no scenario where you can
describe to me where you have your hands
around your partner's neck over the
couch and she's like upside down that
should never be a normal situation in
any relationship irrespec of how you two
treat each other so they need to be
separated so I got no problem with a
straining order and then let the
investigation unfold as it should okay
but I don't like it looks terrible you
got her on the floor at the bottom of
the stairs him walking away shirtless
yeah yeah yeah my man definitely looks
hella guilty it don't look good it don't
it don't look good so you know I I hope
that for the child's sake specifically
um that this thing gets resolved and for
both parties that they go their separate
ways so that they can figure this [__]
out and if somebody's in the wrong they
go to jail for let the investigation
unfold it's pretty simp simple here
there's no like gray area or Gray Zone
you know that is a common thing that
I've been hearing about like people are
controlling threatening themselves yes
to keep the other person in the whole
dynamic like that is a twisted thing yep
it is but I've I've heard that numerous
times person wants to have if you leave
me I don't know what I'll do to myself
like whoa you trying to make me feel and
I'll be honest with y'all I'm going to
say something that's [__] up 100% you
should walk away at that moment
150 75 2,000% you should walk away at
that moment because the moment you give
into that [__] for the first time that
is going to be coming a power play every
single time I don't disagree it sounds
crazy to say I don't disagree I'm not
saying you should encourage it like yeah
go ahead do it do it cuz then that's be
you're walking the line of a crime right
here but you should Craig David that
[__] and walk away y for all the from
all the trouble in your life that that
100% mhm